[Music]
good morning we're actually going to
hear Ali bellow I guess as you know
here's this tension we used you see this
is just always old fits board it always
did everything it needed for Elsa kept
her in a barrier kept me away now Ali
will go in and but Ali gets a little
crazy so we're gonna beat this up that
way it is ready for her to go buckle out
in here because most time we're not
we're not putting her in and locking her
down we're fixing to start because her
stands and training spend to get a
little bit longer a little bit more
intense because she's getting closer to
having a calf so we need to make sure
she is ready so we're going to go ahead
and put the crossbar in to pull her
close to us like we had in the other
stanchion also we're going to beat these
up a little bit to where once we wrap up
and put a chain around them she can't
get out of them and then this backboard
right here which is just old fence post
or a fencing she said oh really one by
six
we're gonna go ahead and beef up put a
2x4 here and get it real tight on her
that way she will be she'll be tough but
she can't jump out and break it down
like like she could with this little
board so I don't think she knows what's
in store for me okay so you see I put a
bolt in my bolt it on this side just got
a simple hook another bolt to this 2x4
now what I'm gonna do is take this 2x4
and use it like it's supposed to be used
and basically I'll pull it in with a
chain against her rear end I there and
that way it keeps her very close to me
where she can't move also when dealing
with that I'm gonna take this take that
to before and brace it right here to
where it keeps her tight against me too
so that way she's encapsulated with
really 2x4 is more than just the look of
a stanchion this tension is beefed up up
top but I never really beefed it up cuz
I never had to but now was like I said
with Ali and kind of training her a
little bit more and she's a little bit
more stubborn and bullheaded I'm gonna
just kind of beef it up but so I've got
this start as you see got that the end
we're gonna go ahead
to the other side put the bolt on it
over here and then finish up right here
and then that way I'm gonna get her in
let her let you see me go ahead and do
extension training on her and then that
way we'll kind of get her prepared okay
so I got it done this bar up I did
secure it in we put this extra
heavier-duty clamp here what we'll do is
have this swing this is just hang like
this until she gets in once she gets in
I just unlatch this you'll drop this
chain and then I'll just put this here
and let it on right there so it's not
gonna be hard
we're just gonna see if this will work
I'm gonna put her in it and I'm so not
stress her out but just kind of leave
her in here especially for foods done
and see if she can still get out we're
trying to get to where she really can't
get out well you got that you know the
feets tension I've never really had to
close it for Elsa I am gonna close it on
Ali's head just because the horns I
don't want to try to warn me so I've got
a chain to go around that too so let's
let's see if we can get her in I'll let
her do some training let her just eat
and kind of calm down and I'm trying to
lock her in and see if it makes a
difference
Hickory I see if we can get her over
getting ready to go
I'll be a lot more alright so there we
go a little bit
okay hey there we go alright so you see
how we got our tighter they say see how
we got her tighter she can't really move
so that's how we got the stitching going
now we're gonna work on a little stanton
training this is how we've been doing
Ally and this is how we kind of keep her
from from actually I'm trying to keep me
so Athens won't go get a towel and also
get some apple cider vinegar spray and
we'll go ahead and least get a little
training done and try to rub on her a
little bit you know the main thing is
letting her feel like she's comfortable
so when the kids are here petting her
and we're just talking around her we've
ran the pump around her I felt all over
but every time she kicks I'll give her a
good pop on my hind leg and that
teachers are know so she's done really
good I mean she really has but you know
standing here for five minutes eating
that's not locked in so now I'm gonna
stand here maybe 30 or 40 minutes locked
in with that our calf being the one in
milker we'll see how that goes but again
training is all part of getting hurt
broken in so Amy's gonna get that stuff
and we'll go and see if we can spray a
little bit show you how we have been
breaking her and Sam just gonna work
hopefully when she has this Dam all
right so this is typically how we mail
again she's she's a lot smaller than
Elsa now you see she's got her leg
behind her I don't know why she's stand
like that we have been working with her
so I'll grab her like I do Elsa and
she'll move her leg back now never seen
her like go behind her so that's a new
trick so we'll see how she does when I
try to feel owner you see that she's not
kicking me yet she used to keep me but
you are close she does have good feed I
don't feed her unless I'm stationed
training her so she sees this a treat
again apple cider vendor here's what we
used to make sure the cow gets covered
and cleaned off we want to train her
like we were just now moving her so
she's kind of see she trying to just
come on say Scrabble right there and
show using a judge she may do it again
cuz she's still trying to work on
training you say yeah I'm just trying to
just get her used to me to fill in older
she's doing goodness she do you never
never get comfortable even with the
calots you've been training for a while
unless you are you're comfortable with
her milking for even a year or two as uh
Elsa I'm comfortable with but just
because she's been milking almost a year
I don't want to ever think that that
eight eight nine hundred thousand pound
cow can I you know hurt me well this
one's smaller but she's even more feisty
and she's not used to milk and I want to
make sure she's comfortable and the last
thing I'll do is just trust her I put my
head down here and try to get her I try
to just trust her that way so we're just
gonna do a little bit more training
stand here eat let me just kind of mess
with her as if I was fish no milker none
any bond
it's just loosely around her neck so it
makes her feel like she's she's there
but it's not where she is choking or
anything like that you've got plenty of
room ally getting petted by Ellie Ellie
be careful baby
so she's fighting her again she's been
training good there's always remember if
she decides to try to keep pop it right
here now she hadn't done it so it won't
pop I won't hurt just know that she's
doing a really good job but I'll give
her if she does good on my kid girl good
job and I just love owner rubber belly
and just kind of let her know that I she
has done a great job but there's a
different command than where she starts
to try to kick me or tries to put her
leg in front
I'll give her a gentle pop here if she
doesn't do it then I'll grab back here
and then that way she knows I'm trying
to teach her that's two commands I do
with her now your kill may be different
and you may have different ways to train
your cow but the main thing is you want
to be able to say a command and she
knows what you're talking about like I
can say two or three commands with with
Elsa and she knows I don't like her
using the restroom intention and she's
learned that I can say and she will not
do it until she's done but it's because
I've just steady trained her
same way if else is not close enough I
can grab her just like I'm trying to
teach Ali back here just kind of barely
touch her and she'll notice step over
now with Ali I've got her tight to me so
she don't have to worry about trying to
step over however what we're trying to
do with her is just make sure she can
move her leg back so you see how she's
standing it's perfect for me that's
exactly how I want her to stand with
that left leg back just a little bit so
that way I can get either at a hand milk
or put a pump owner and that way she
mean she's doing really good
how much do you sense and train you need
to have your cow way before she has her
baby if she's not used to you she's not
gonna be used to estancia she's not
gonna be used to you hand milking even
even Elsa who was a a milk cow and
milked for a long time at a milk barn
local milk Marne she still took hurt a
long time just to get used to us now
she's used to us but still you want to
make sure that you have your cow you
love with your cap she gets to know
y'all just to know you she knows your
commands and then that way you know when
she's ready to start extension training
now say she's getting ready to have a
cat well I started extensive training in
alle pride about three four months ago
halfway through a pregnancy because I
want her to get used to it the only time
she gets feed and all this good sweet
food and all this very pellets is only
when she comes in the stanchion there's
times you can ask a a you can vouch for
me hey that's we would not feed her and
all sudden she's walking the stanchion
walk right back out well she didn't get
any feed that day so we're teaching her
this is a treat only when you come in to
get milked and when you're good if she
starts kicking and she wouldn't abide to
the stanchion room we would not keep her
in here and she would do we take her
feet away and that way she new for the
day she messed up and she don't want to
do that look at this her real right here
she's so big with this calf that she is
like poking out on the ribs so I think
she's doing good what what do you think
I think she's gonna do she might
surprise this and they better than I
think as long as she's eaten she'll let
you do anything you want to so um so
it's like
she's done great I mean we won't know
until all the time gets here but I think
the more that we keep working with her
the better she's gonna do of course
right four months ago I couldn't even
touch her here she'd run out of things
she has those horns which is one of her
big things where she's just she's not
natured as much like Elsa which was one
of our concerns they also just she don't
care what you did to her Ali's a little
bit different so training Ali it was
very important and see we've already
bought a calf halter and we're gonna
wrap it around here before she is an eye
view of her cow her cab that will also
let help her milk come out okay bro
we're dealing with her jerseys are
notorious for holding back their milk
for their calf which is where their
cream is so the more they hold back the
more cream we won't get so we're gonna
put that cap right there in front of her
where she knows how important it is to
let her let her fool milk down we're not
gonna be over fully out like we would
Elsa because we won't hurt get good and
fed good she is put on some weight for
this cash she's not normally this big at
all so but she's doing really good I'm
very pleased with her um again part of
statue training is making making sure
you're getting comfortable with a cow
but more than that the cow getting
comfortable with you she needs to know
your commands if a pop right here is
what teaches our cows that that's wrong
that's what she needs to know if a
grabbing her here teaches her that's
what we need when we want her leg moved
that's what she needs to know if we know
aunt is a bad command when she's trying
to do things she shouldn't be doing like
pulling away from the top here the V
then she needs to know but she won't
know that if you had trained her over
the last few weeks or months cows are
not don't know they can be stubborn but
they're not dumb so learn to give them
treats just like you would a dog or any
other animals at the same time make sure
you're rewarding them taking care of
them and they'll take care of you
hope this video is a good old video
teaches
you have we stench and train our heifers
as they get ready to cap and we hope you
have good day we hope you're enjoying
our content of our Channel
all right we say illing happy
homesteading
[Music]